je préfère mon sol
c'est avec ces mots simples que
christopher 6 conclu son discours le
bronze autour du cou le cavalier revient
tout juste de tokyo ait fait cette belle
médaille avec ses proches où on était
toujours derrière lui à fond depuis le
début mois là ça fait 15 ans qu'on le
connaît donc du coup
on est très très très très heureux pour
lui sa première fois que j'ai vu une
médaille alors ça ne fait
lisieux et il a gagné
et maintenant il se serait une star ni
d'accueil une star des écuries qui n'a
pourtant failli ne pas être à ce grand
rendez vous avec son cheval totem de
brécé il devait être réserviste mais
christopher 6 a bénéficié du forfait
d'un autre cavalier français pour gagner
son ticket pour tokyo ces jeux
olympiques était donc aussi l'occasion
de faire ses preuves forcément moi
c'était ma première olympiade donc ce
qui n'était pas le cas de mes deux
camarades
nicolas touzaint et karim laghouag donc
mois déjà bah fallait que je fasse mes
preuves auprès du staff fédéral leur
montrer que
j'étais capable de tenir la pression
parce que sur les jeux olympiques on a
la pression j'avais à coeur de ramener
une médaille est de montrer que j'étais
capable de faire sécher en cela pour sa
compagne chloé jeunet qui l'a accompagné
à tokyo c'est une médaille qui revient
aussi à tout un staff c'est une très
grande satisfaction et on est content
que c'est puis aboutira peut-être belle
médaille c'est également une réussite
d'équipé avec nos piliers qui étaient
ici on a on a trois employés à plein
temps ici antoine mallory et chloé qui
ont continué de faire fonctionner
l'écurie en notre absence et oui on peut
que pense à elles et les remercier parce
que si on n'avait pas
une équipe pareille on pourrait pas
s'absenter aussi longtemps et je pense
que la concentration n'aurait pas été la
même donc c'est aussi leur réussit
désormais christoper stick savoure sa
victoire mais pense déjà à l'avenir dans
trois ans il espère remporter une
nouvelle médaille olympique à paris
cette fois